[Musica]
[Applauso]
Sarò sincero con voi
Il problema è che noi tutti vogliamo una
quotidianità
in cui potremo prima o poi sentirci
sostenibili
però allo stesso tempo vogliamo
continuare ad andare a fare la spesa e
trovare al supermercato prodotti che
vengono da ogni più recondita parte del
mondo
così come vogliamo pompare la serotonina
a comando facendo acquisti nella nostra
catena di fast fashion preferita o non
farci mai mancare nel ponte dell'otto di
dicembre di andare a sciare su
chilometri di piste innevate
artificialmente o naturalmente
e pretendiamo che qualcuno trovi la
soluzione
per far sì che tutto questo diventi
sostenibile
C'è però un problema
la soluzione non esiste
e quello che vorremmo che qualcuno
facciasse è questo se qualcuno trovi il
modo di sostituire l'idolo della vecchia
tecnologia con il sacchetto di sabbia
della nuova ma sappiamo tutti come è
andata a finire Rischiamo solo di essere
inseguiti e speriamo non schiacciati dal
rotolante macigno dell'indeluttabile
destino che ci attende perché diversi
sono i problemi c'è un problema di
tecnologia in certi casi non abbiamo la
tecnologia da sostituire la precedente o
non è ancora pronta per arrivare sul
mercato
In altri casi Abbiamo un problema di
risorse è proprio di questi giorni di
questi tempi la domanda sul fatto che ci
sia litio a sufficienza per alimentare
1,5 miliardi di veicoli che solcano le
nostre strade che ci sia energia
rinnovabile per alimentarli e rete
elettrica adeguate
e infine
l'ultima cosa che ci manca è il tempo
perché noi
vogliamo che tutti gli aspetti della
nostra vita diventino sostenibili se
davvero a quello puntiamo e non abbiamo
idea di quanto tempo serva così come non
abbiamo idea di quanto tempo ci rimane
e il mio discorso potrebbe finire qua
oggi
ma sarebbe un discorso di tanats la
pulsione verso la distruzione senza il
sentimento posto Eros ma voglio ben
sperare che se voi avete scelto di
essere qui oggi non siate quel tipo di
persone che davanti a un mondo che
brucia si stappano una birra si mettono
a sedere e si aprono un pacchetto di
patatine
Allora se vogliamo sedurre il sentimento
opposto alla distruzione bisogna che in
qualche modo ci addentriamo nei
meccanismi di come la nostra società ha
una transizione verso il futuro
qual è però il problema
è che l'assenza di una soluzione banale
della soluzione fa sì che l'umanità si
sia persa
si è persa in un luogo che essa stessa
ha creato un luogo che io chiamo la
foresta socio tecnologica e se oggi
parliamo di abilità sostegno ability
l'abilità di cui vi voglio parlare è
l'opposto del perdersi e l'orientamento
e uno dei dogmi dell'orientamento è
quello di saper osservare e quindi
assieme oggi osserviamo e capiamo come
costruita questa foresta
la foresta socio tecnologica È un luogo
immaginario in cui ogni tecnologia del
nostro presente è lì e rappresenta una
specie un albero un animale le felci o
altro c'è la macchina c'è il POS per il
pagamento contactless con la carta di
credito
ci sono le cannucce biodegradabili
c'è anche le racchette da padella o da
tennis
ogni tecnologia che popola il nostro
presente e lì e rappresenta una specie
se continuo però la mia osservazione mi
rendo conto che a governare questo luogo
non siamo noi o quantomeno non abbiamo
più il volante in mano a governare
questo luogo e la Simbiosi e il secondo
problema di cui mi rendo conto è che la
nostra esistenza qui in questo luogo non
è data da per scontata perché abbiamo
creato qualcosa in cui forse noi non
possiamo sopravvivere urge Quindi che ci
mettiamo in moto e troviamo luoghi nuovi
Dove possiamo stare per un tempo
indefinito ed è quello il significato
etimologico della sostenibilità come
nella musica su Stein lasciare una nota
finché vogliamo
Simbiosi e coevoluzione governano questo
luogo perché ogni tecnologia non è lì da
sola permettetevi di fare qualche
esempio
l'automobile come la conosciamo noi
è figlia di un processo di evoluzione
con una miriade di altre tecnologie
pensate a quanta Tecnologia c'è
un'automobile oggi ma cose molto più
semplici se l'automobile oggi ha gli
pneumatici è perché le strade sono fatte
da asfalto e il fatto che abbiamo
coperto il mondo d'asfalto è perché le
automobili hanno gli pneumatici
coevoluzione E questo vale per tutto
fino arrivare a concetti come il
pagamento a rate oppure l'assicurazione
In un ecosistema in cui per qualche
motivo non si è mai sviluppata la specie
assicurazione o pagamento a rate
Allora la spesa automobile si sarebbe
sviluppata in qualcosa di molto più
economico e probabilmente con una
velocità di punta molto più bassa perché
saremo tutti terrorizzati di fare dei
danni E questo vale per ogni cosa Se
esiste il fast fashion E perché questo
alimentato e si è fatto alimentare dalla
produzione di fibre tessili sintetica a
basso costo ha permesso di costruire
sistemi in cui possiamo sfruttare la
forza lavoro hai in qualche modo
beneficiato e fatto beneficiare le
tinture chimiche
questo vale per ogni tecnologia
Dobbiamo però continuare la nostra
osservazione perché non si finisce qui
perché se io guardo attorno ai nostri
piedi mentre camminiamo in questa
foresta in questo ecosistema complesso
di tecnologie
vedo che ci sono specie nuove che
costantemente tentano di trovare il loro
posto in questo luogo ma che falliscono
Queste sono le nuove tecnologie sono
l'innovazione E fate bene attenzione Io
parlo sia dell'Innovazione scientifica
rinchiusa dentro le porte dell'Accademia
dove si sviluppano nuovi materiali o
cose mirabolanti ma parlo anche allo
stesso modo dell'Innovazione sistemica
di chi sta cercando di fare le cose in
modo nuovo come muoversi fare la spesa o
curarsi
ma il problema è che la lotta È una
lotta impari non è la lotta della
bicicletta che sfida l'auto non è la
nuova tecnologia o L'innovazione che
sfida la vecchia tecnologia
non è il litio che sfida il gasolio non
sono i Farmers Market che sfidano la
grande distribuzione organizzata il
problema qua è che ogni innovazione è
chiamata sfidare un intero ecosistema
affinato e affilato in cui tutti gli
attori sono in relazione ed ognuno di
essi si ostina fortemente al cambiamento
Allora c'è speranza potrebbe finire di
nuovo il mio discorso Oggi c'è speranza
per L'innovazione di nascere all'interno
degli ecosistemi di tecnologie che noi
abbiamo creato
la risposta è sì
ma per rispondere dobbiamo continuare a
osservare e che cos'è che non avevamo
ancora osservato l'ambiente
Perché Cos'è che fa sì che una foresta
si sviluppi in un certo modo e
l'ambiente e la quota a cui si è
sviluppato quanto solo può prendere la
prossimità di un corso d'acqua
l'ambiente decide che foresta si
sviluppa lì tropicale Montana di pianura
e che cos'è l'ambiente per noi
l'ambiente Quelle insieme di valori sono
concetti intangibili sono le nostre
preoccupazioni sono le scale in cui noi
mettiamo i nostri valori cosa ci
interessa e che cosa non ci interessa
che cosa è sacrificabile che cosa non è
sacrificabile
questo determina l'ambiente dentro il
quale si costruiscono e sviluppano le
nostre foreste
una società che ad esempio pone il
raggiungimento dell'età adulta
oppure il concetto di indipendenza
con il conseguimento della patente di
guida potrà mai
favorire e fomentare il trasporto
pubblico
Se ad esempio noi mettiamo concetti come
il successo
o la felicità in cose che stanno fuori
dell'individuo quanto possiede che
obiettivi Ha raggiunto potremmo mai
creare sistemi che favoriscono il
consumo critico ma stiamo molto più nel
semplice se ad esempio la qualità di un
veicolo coincide con la sua velocità di
punta noi nel nostro piccolo
selezioniamo così quella specie
ma per nostra fortuna i valori non sono
scritti nella pietra questi cambiano a
volte molto lentamente col cambiare
degli Usi dei costumi dei popoli nella
loro storia a volte più velocemente
pensate anche solo come l'aumento del
costo dei combustibili fossili ha spinto
nei recenti anni porzioni sempre
crescenti della popolazione a fare
scelte che noi ora chiamiamo ecologiche
a volte i nostri valori cambiano di
punto in bianco come Allo scoppio di una
guerra o come Quando scoppia una
pandemia o infine quando il cambiamento
climatico si manifesta Con l'ennesimo
fenomeno atmosferico che questa volta
bussa a casa mia
da un giorno all'altro è reale
da un giorno all'altro non ne posso più
si percepisce l'urgenza che ieri non
c'era i nostri valori e le nostre
priorità sono cambiate
e torniamo alla nostra storia quindi
alla nostra foresta le nostre foreste
Che cosa significa cambiare i nostri
valori
significa mettersi in cammino verso
luoghi nuovi
luoghi dove la pressione l'affinità
ecologica di questo ecosistema inizia a
vacillare perché qua si è sviluppato e
ha affilato le sue armi i luoghi nuovi
le faggete lasciano spazio alle Pinete
cambiando l'ambiente cambiando i nostri
valori Creiamo un contesto dentro il
quale nuove foreste si possono
Sviluppare e speriamo che siano popolate
di quell'innovazione che avevamo scovato
e poi da lì ancora continueremo a
camminare in questo costante
vagabondare che noi chiamiamo progresso
e quindi erano altre domande che
dovevamo farci non dovevamo chiederci
qual è la soluzione perché la soluzione
non esiste Dovevamo farci domande con
gli occhi rivolti verso il cielo a
questo ambiente uscire di qua e
chiederci che forma stiamo dando le
foreste socio tecnologiche che popolano
la nostra vita e le nostre città Quali
sono i nostri valori le cose che ci
stanno a cuore in che modo le nostre
azioni
rispecchiano queste scale di valori e
come fare dilagare questa cosa come
smuovere le coscienze delle nuove e
delle vecchie generazioni
Queste sono domande verso l'ambiente per
farlo cambiare e costringere gli
ecosistemi ad adattarsi
e poi dovevamo fare domande con gli
occhi puntati per terra all'innovazione
che nasce Perché non possiamo
calpestarla nel nostro vagabondare
perché questa innovazione ci servirà ci
servirà là dove stiamo andando perché là
dovrà Popolare le nuove foreste della
nostra società
e quindi chiediamoci se questa società
si prende cura dell'Innovazione che sta
nascendo se la tutela
se l'alimenta sia l'innovazione
scientifica sia chi in modo sistemico
sta provando a fare le cose in modo
nuovo nella mia scuola nel mio quartiere
nelle nostre città
Queste sono domande con gli occhi per
terra
e quindi questi estremi ci salveranno
innovazione ed educazione Perché dove
non saprà arrivare l'innovazione
Dovremmo arrivare noi con piccole e
grandi rivoluzioni copernicane delle
nostre esistenze delle nostre vite e
delle nostre città significa prendersi
cura delle collettività diventando
persone quindi politiche senza mai
essere però polemiche perché il
cambiamento non si può forzare il
cambiamento si manifesta quando il
terreno per ospitarlo è pronto
[Applauso]